alors les terriens de ce soir
kad merad
tamera bonsoir j'ai vu arriver tout à
l'heure sur le plateau disons bonjour à
tous les techniciens c'est vrai que
j'avais pas chopé la grosse tête vous
êtes resté simple ouais pourquoi pas
dispo en même temps ça sert à quoi
d'être une star de cinéma si on peut
être désagréable avec tout le monde
n'y arrive pas vous allez finir par
dégoûter les jeunes de vouloir faire
acteur cadre
également avec nous ce soir olivier
barrot
ça fait plaisir de voir tous les deux
leur il tombe on rêvait d'une
réformation caillé s'est fait annoncer
aubert et bertignac
l'émission s'appelle salut les terriens
et le groupe g gréement de fortune
[Musique]
bien rares cas des euro bonds soir vous
êtes ici ce soir pour un film intitulé
mais qui a retué pamela rose il y sort
mercredi 5 décembre dans lequel dix ans
après le premier épisode vous renouer
avec l'esprit de vos débuts à la radio
sur scène à la télé c'est vrai que quoi
que vous ayez fait depuis les gens
continuent à vous parler de pamela rose
et vous demande de faire une suite donc
vous l'avez fait ouais il ya deux choses
qui reviennent quand on rencontre
publique c'est le cas à bouloc c'est un
mélange voilà est un peu main et à saint
[Applaudissements]
pierre on va avoir raté de trouver un
truc quoi vanitas et
alors qui a retué pamela rose raconte
donc la suite des aventures de deux
flics pathétique bulitt et reaper
membres du fbi sur une trame policière
qui tient la route et c'est bourré de
gags de vannes d'absurde c'est no limit
quoi c'est la condition faite pour qu'on
le fasse très bien les y lâchez vous
fait que oui ça se voit sur le question
avec julien rappeneau également
co-scénariste et déjà du premier film
moi j'ai vu je le dis c'est très marrant
j'adore n'est mise en abyme au bout
d'une heure de film
4 là ça fait qu'une heure que le film
doit durer une heure et demie qu'est ce
qu'on fait maintenant ça repart est
aussi le directeur de production qui
arrivent en disant non en fait on peut
pas c'est trop cher il ya plein de trucs
un peu mel brooks siens comme ça si on
l'a vécu en fait on a vécu sera un peu
on avait des petites sommes d'argent et
donc on s'est dit on va le mettre dans
ce film quoi on a plus de tunes koi pour
faire les hélicoptères les avions hills
où barbra et nadia le dire vrai avec
diane ça drôle il ya beaucoup
d'autodérision il ya un personnage à un
moment qui murmure à l'oreille de cadres
attention tu tournes trop
oui c'est vrai mais je continue quand
même tu vois ton bladi on va dire cette
année de trois cimes savons déjà c'est
pas beaucoup un parapentiste lever le
pied quand même avec toutes ces cinq
films par an j'aime ça c'est mon boulot
il paraît que des fois vous dit à
l'animateur quand vous arrivez sur un
plateau c'est quoi le film la
scat quand on vous dit qu'on vous voit
trop vous dites j'ai vu mon père partir
travailler tous les jours à 7 heures du
matin et rentrer à 9 heures du soir
travailler c'est tous les jours non
serre que j'ai été élevé dans le dans le
travail quoique c1 c'est comme si on
disait il à la mer aujourd'hui tu vas
pas l'hôpital louis-h tu ne vas pas nous
c'est un peu c'est un peu notre boulot a
donc c'est un peu facile bon enfin bon
ce sont je me défends pas je m'en fous
surtout moi je continue dans mais je
suis en bosses quoi tout va bien à quoi
bon boulot chez
aux passagers toujours autant que toi
alors qu'harry êtes effectivement
aujourd'hui l'un des acteurs les plus
bankable du cinéma français l'affairé
des français je vous ai fait 20 millions
d'entrées avec les ch'tis c'est vrai
avait été couronné par l'académie des
césar c'est vrai vous avez lu la
déclaration des droits de l'homme c'est
vraiment un 14 juillet place de la
concorde mort en france et non les mecs
qui y avaient appelé angela merkel il
est pas cher c'est l'époque où les
développeurs il ya aussi ce jour là
j'aurais aimé qu'ils fassent m'a dit tu
as de la vitesse savais même pas que je
serais tu es mieux vous êtes une star
internationale voulait qu'on continue
l'interview en anglais là non oui parce
que c'est vrai non non mais ce qui veut
dire tirer que j'ai plus l'habitude
membres exprimé en anglais c'est
évidemment là les états unis normalement
lundi 28 pays limitrophes mais n'en
réclame alors olivier quand on est avec
lui comme vous en ce moment pour la
promo on n'a pas l'impression d'être le
mari de la reine d'angleterre toute la
journée il ya pas mal davantage je
dirais que là on a une voiture on a un
chauffeur
avalant des bons restos on se marre
comme on se pose pas de question donc
voilà est-ce que vous personnellement
vous avez souffert du succès de cad
absolument pas j'en ai toujours été fier
et je me le dire honnêtement ça m'a aidé
aussi à faire mais mon second film après
ce soir devant chez toi et donc voilà et
je sais c'est bon d'avoir un ami cad
regardez trop haut trop fort on va faire
une interview autodestruction
ça normalement c'est pour l'ump autour
de structures oui c'est vrai que
j'aurais pu vous la perle au fait
qu'est-ce que vous ne supportez pas
c'est kad merad
sa connerie tout le temps mais le temps
lui jamais sortir des conneries toute la
journée pour juste pour amuser soit
olivier soit soin de faire cela c'est à
dire de tout le temps chercher quatre
représentations eh ouais mais en même
temps je savais chasse j'aime ça c'est
comme ça vous êtes en même temps là donc
je dis des conneries forcément parfois
une association ya du déchet quand avez
vous eu envie de gifler kad merad pour
la dernière fois
peut-être hier soir tête quel droit je
suis un peu sorti donc le gg univers de
verre 3 vers 4 vers 5 vers divers quatre
bouteilles et ans à la fin tu voi le mec
fait monsieur marage et plus rien à voir
mais parce qu'il avait un accent le mec
gt r d dans le travail et dans l'apéro
l'arrêt chez nous il y avait le bureau
tout le temps d'arrêt il boit toujours
d'ailleurs
raison rainurés l'académie mohammed vi
voit même année de salut pour des jours
ouais bah c'est à dire que je me suis à
ses visions et des apéros c'est
vachement important chez après midi soir
maintenant parfois un apéro à 7 heures
du matin allez on peut l'appeler papa il
est 7h grosso arrivé 7e bon là tant
mieux
parce qu'ils squattent le ricard
attention à quelle occasion avez-vous eu
marre d'être kad merad
oh là là bas c'est ça hier soir alors
donc à ce rang oui parce que bon elle
était très très jeune en fait un autre
[Musique]
tiens justement la planchette la
prochaine question c'est à quelle
occasion kad merad mieux fait de fermer
sa gueule
enfin plein d'occasions mais je sais pas
ça tu vas peut-être m'aider plein de
fois tu gaffe pas mal de fois depuis je
fais des gaffes ouais ça fait des gaffes
politiques vous arrêtez pas
mais c'est bon
parce que on est toujours en train de
s'exprimer de parler donc on dit des
conneries dernière question et non la
moindre qu'est-ce que kad merad aura
raté dans sa vie
ma carrière de batteur oui
et votre coupe de cheveux
de squale est ce qu a les cheveux
sabatier j'ai des cheveux en fait un
blessé léger mais ce dont les âges tout
le temps en fait dans les files dans les
films vous avez souvent des périodes des
filles adorent samoa mais on adore se
déguiser dans paris larousse est un
festival en festival météo parce que tu
as on est obligé de rades époque j'avais
des cheveux non non
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
leonard itunes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux